you guys we have something very special
it's eclipse channel if you haven't
already
this is a great way to see um episode
highlights
um send your friend a highlight if
you've been wanting them to get on board
listen there we have we have editors up
all night
tirelessly editing these things okay
their fingers are bleeding we're calling
them no
not that one no our chins look bad in
that one our hair looks shitty in that
then we took neutrophil it actually
still works but check out the [ __ ]
clips channel guys all right make it
worth their time don't forget to check
out our eclipse channel
subscribe and like all the videos and
share them with your friends
oh and on top of that go on itunes
please
yes five star it out just give us the
five stars over and over again
we'd really really appreciate that you
guys want t-shirts for it do we have
those ready
give us reviews just give us reviews
we're gonna
we're gonna select some reviews on
itunes and you're going to get
free t-shirts so they're going to be
blank
but no they're not there's going to be
plain white shirts but
we're going to come here aren't you
lucky
esther what are you sad about well i saw
see spiricy on netflix and
it was really difficult to watch because
you were born underwater
well i wish as a bottom feeder
i really like sushi so i went vegan four
years ago and then
after a year of being vegan i was like
i'm gonna have just sushi that's gonna
be my cheat
so that's like my only non-veg so i know
that makes me not vegan but like
i love sushi so much and but she goes
she only has it like once or twice or
three times a week so it's not
esther did you become a vegan because of
a netflix documentary yeah yeah she's a
listen she's a nothing's vegan what the
hell you're a netflix vegan
i watched what the health i'm honestly
you're the reason i never watched these
pakistani or these uh
netflix shows anymore because they were
you so you didn't watch these spirits
i watched what the health after you and
then i was like should i be and then i
want to be [ __ ] vegan there's no part
of me that wants to be vegan
and when i look at conspiracy and i see
what like i already like blackfish was
enough
now i can't go to sea world anymore i
can't jerk off telecom
blackfish i can i can stand by a lot
more than see spirits like there are a
lot of
truths about just industrial fishing
that's so [ __ ] up
but there's also a lot of like like
willful misinformation by that
documentarian i think that's really
really the agenda of um veganism and
really and that's what i got like i
and also like i had a lot of qualms
about it like even when they talked
about the philippines and like
the animation that came up it's this
thing called alibata which i write it's
a dead language like they
the documentarian thought that that's
our written language like we haven't
used it as a country in like
500 [ __ ] years so there's tiny little
things like i had issues with but um
um i have a friend she's a spear fisher
woman her name is valentine thomas
and i think that we should call her with
your sushi questions
okay now i will say that i did also just
watch
jaws and i was like all right [ __ ] the
sea creatures
they're evil eat them before they eat
you and it is
by the way have you seen jaws yes i have
yeah
do you guys know that it's like it's
like um
it's like a precursor to covid because
they're like
we can't shut the beach down for the
economy
but it's like kovac but you do realize
that
we wiped away sharks apex predators we'd
be
done right we need them we absolutely
need sharks i love sharks don't talk
[ __ ] about sharks
that's like if you got rid of me on the
podcast annie this is a good question to
ask about your um
plastic straws because i think that that
that was mentioned on there
that was my one like the woohoo moment
when they're like the plastic isn't even
that big of a deal and i was like
all my friends who've bitched at me for
buying cheap things on black friday made
of plastic
or drinking with plastic straws and like
i was vegan okay i was doing better than
you [ __ ]
what are you buying on black friday
that's that's causing a stir with all
your fries i went to menards
in the midwest on black friday two years
ago and i bought like this plastic neon
cactus for 4.99
and one to two people complained yeah
you've been holding on to it
yes i'm still upset i was too poor to
shop on black friday i worked black
friday
for 18 straight hours at abercrombie and
fitch at the glendale galleria just
folding folding foaming oh you still i
know you still work there
wow delilah maybe take a break they call
you a gold digger but
[Music]
okay let's call it see spirit see your
friend who knows stuff
her it's weird her name is here
c dot spiricy hello hi it's kalyla
so you're on the show you're on
bloodbath and um
esther has some um
very very important questions to ask you
about her sushi intake so i'm gonna pass
the phone over to you if that's
okay okay thank you so much for taking
the time to talk to us so what do you do
um so i have a job that doesn't really
exist
um i i'm a professional speaker woman
which is not really a thing
uh i used to be a lawyer and then like
kind of put everything to uh
guys around the world and educate people
on
it's unfair i am just stressed out from
watching this
show see spirit see i'm like there's no
such thing as sustainable seafood all
those labels
that say things are sustainable and
dolphins safe are lies
out the the how they catch by catch in
the nets like is it true should i never
have sushi again is it really
evil and there's no safe friendly way to
do this
no it's actually not true i mean they're
quite good are true like the fact that
you know there are horrible things
happening in the fishing industry but
people
should not stop eating seizures i think
the united states has probably
one of the most sustainable fisheries in
the world so
what else you can do is keep it excess
but just keep eating
local fish eat local fish yeah
so we want domestic united states fish
we don't want fish that needed a
passport to get here
all right id only now what
what like on what's on the sushi menu
that's local
uh you probably have yellowtown
yellowtail
uh you have my he's also very
how about careful with salmon yeah
because it's like farm salmon is
oh yeah that's because there's farms
that are pretty shitty and there's farms
that are pretty great
okay so there is a way you just have to
ask around try to find local
how do i find the good farm fish
it's sadly by doing research
which is very bad oh yeah
just hire someone to do it dear annie
okay well valentine thank you so much
i'm gonna hand you off to kala in case
there's
more questions annie do you have
questions no i don't care i'm eating i
i don't care where the fish comes from
eating it
i don't have any children what does that
have to do let's sink this ship
i'm saying let's sink donut will be gone
in ten years
hey thank you so much for answering um
esther has just
been grieving for a whole week over her
possible
possibly never eating fish again thank
you so much for answering our questions
and i hope the next time you come out to
california we can all go on a boat with
you and we can teach esther how to
swim spear a fish catch a fish
bye bye esther you're going to go from
netflix vegan to a fish murderer this is
going to be oh that's what
i've ever seen that's what i wanted to
tell her that you were a netflix vegan
oh but she's she's
honestly she's all gold i love finding a
woman
that is goals that's like i can't even
imagine anymore the days of like
oh someone is perfect and i'm jealous
i'm just like you're
i'm working towards you although i will
admit one day
when i discovered kate upton and that
she was like five years younger than me
and that my time had come and gone i was
like
you know what it is it's when they're
younger and they already they're like
super rich super like
a seeming like they seem very happy and
they already have kids and it seems very
chill
it's like i'm like you have like five
kids already and you're seven years
younger than me
like what the [ __ ] like the days of
thing i was gonna be a young mother have
been gone for like a decade
you know yeah speaking of you said let's
sink the ship
i when i was in boston i met someone
who's an ancestor of a
survivor of the titanic how cool i was
like ah
tell me everything like isn't that cool
tell me about how your great
grandmother's
friends all died and their family his
grandma
jumped into a lifeboat and was on a
lifeboat with
70 people on it and they were on it for
like five hours and he said that the
lifeboat was so
um heavy like there was too many people
on it
that there was only this much of like
you know six inches of the boat
above the water and that like her hair
was in the water frozen
just like who did you most identify with
in the movie like which
group of people the diamond being just
like so precious by people just throwing
me away
just losing me in the scene
who did you identify with i identified
with the drunk musicians
you remember them they just kept playing
the band they just kept drinking until
but they didn't hop into a lifeboat um
but i not to be cocky but i really feel
like i would have survived it
i have said that every tsunami i'm like
i was a tsunami i can't survive
i was a swimmer it's like so and then
you watch you're like oh i guess
let me tell you about a tsunami like oh
i guess maybe not
i've thought about this when i was
younger i was like oh i'm just going to
grab a boogie board and just go with a
direct drive
why are they fighting against it but
it's not these things go 500
500 miles per hour and there's debris
and [ __ ] smacking into you and you can
i have reoccurring nightmares about
tsunamis that's my number one tornadoes
are second but first is tsunami
all the time that's so interesting i
never have a nightmare like that
i think it's because i grew up in the
tropics yeah but it's funny
you say that you think you'd survive the
titanic because
it sounds like the way his grandmother
survived was because she was hot
because she the night before had like
sparked a connection with a guy
and then when it was sinking the guy
like ran into her
and was like come with me that's why
guys never date musicians they'll stay
on the boat they'll get drunk they'll
stay on the boat they won't help you
also when i was little and i saw the
musician thing like them you know
playing i was like so confused but now
as an adult i sort of understand
yeah i'd be up there and i'd be like
listen uncircumcised dicks are crazy
let's go now stand up people are like
i'd be like what
people are jumping into the water
oh they're already in the focus women
and children first that's right
i'd be also doing a black sound all of a
sudden they're like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa what
can't culture appropriate on their way
out actually you can i'd be wearing
these
i feel like if there was a club in there
annie we'd die we'd still be in the club
somewhere like
sucking dick for two like sucking some
wrestling she's gonna be asleep she
wouldn't even know it was happening
she's sound asleep um there was one time
in high school where
in high school we had three separate
buildings and you'd have to go from
building a b
and c but there was a tunnel to connect
them and one time someone blew up
an m80 which is really loud and um
during um
in the middle of periods when everyone
was in the tunnel and um
initially i thought it was a gun shot
that had gone off
and everyone like ducked down except for
my sister and i
my sister and i stood up zigzag stepped
on everyone's heads
in the tunnel and ran the [ __ ] out of
there like we ran past the school like
we just skipped school we didn't even go
back to school we were like oh
we're [ __ ] out of here which is why i
think i'd survive at titanic when
there's an awesome
read it's also i can't read it was
reading class that day and when there's
a fire drills difference in any building
at all they're like oh it's everyone's
like it's just a drill let's fall in
line that's run out
i'm out that [ __ ] i'm in my car i'm
driving away in case the whole thing
collapses like that's my
instinct what was with the running
zigzag out
in case someone had a gun oh you didn't
watch cops you didn't watch game of
thrones either wait
but why did everyone duck oh well i
think that's
the natural response is to kind of
decide from it
yeah she was escaping rather than i was
escaping i didn't want to be there
so we were like my sister and i were so
in sync she was like why is that
how did you guys both know she would
have stepped in her head we were new to
this country didn't know watch some bad
movies
we just knew we had to like get the [ __ ]
out of there cops is what taught me the
exactly they're like they can't get you
with they're trying to get you at the
light
they just get your heel i mean like you
have to consider too that
all i watched when i first came here was
jenny jones ricky lake
cops occasionally an old episode of
cheers
very educational you learned all the
good things yeah
i mean jenny jones was yeah jenny they
all were doing
what was your favorite did you watch the
show the makeovers the makeovers the
best right
when you'd have like an old bully come
and see your glow up
oh my god that was the best one but then
jenny jones they had to cancel because
that guy killed his like
the guy that had a crush on him oh
really that's why jenny jones got
canceled jenny jones did like
where people would come out as like
crushes to each other like it would be
like i would come on and then you would
be like
i've been trying to figure you this
whole time i'd be like i have to act
surprised like oh my god
um but so they would like do crushes and
there was one where it was like a
guy had a crush on his neighbor and the
guy
and he like played it off on the show
like he was fine and then he went and he
killed him
oh [ __ ] wait who killed who the
guy this the straight guy but he
obviously i mean that's
seems not very straight that's like
triggered by it the guy who was the guy
that
had the crush on him got killed so there
was a there was a gay guy that that was
neighbors with this apparently straight
guy but i think that action is
the gay man came out and said i have a
crush on you my straight neighbor and
then a straight neighbor later
afterwards killed him i i do think
that's kind of tricky though because
in a way you're sort of outing somebody
right like even though he's
maybe not going on there and saying like
hey i'm not gay but then you're kind of
like
i and back then like you couldn't that
wasn't a thing like we didn't know not
to out people like we would
out anyone we knew we'd like oh he's gay
for sure he's gay like we don't do that
now you know
certainly not on like there was no
outing though because it was a gay man
saying he was attracted to the straight
man
but i think this straight was so
triggered by like the embarrassment
or being on stage with another with a
gay man professing his love like because
back in the day like i had some really
really homophobic friends
who would like beat up like like gay
dudes that would like express
interest in them right they'd be so
defensive and probably because they were
gay themselves
yes and they would get whatever the
standard response that ever that guys
would say like i don't care if you're
gay just don't hit on me
yeah that that's like first of all you
don't get hit on
take the [ __ ] compliments but i feel
like those days
i don't i don't see that as much no but
i also i'm not gay so i'm not seeing
what happens to gay people
but we i could see how like the straight
man and that scenario
in like our hyper masculine is important
culture like
felt ambushed in yeah and like scared
and like emasculated or something but
there might be mental you have to be so
mentally ill yeah
like there's obviously like triggered
like no i'm not defending
if he was secure in any way he would
have been like annie said like
oh thank you thank you no thanks not
interested but thank you
yeah but i feel like i feel like guys
are now like catching on to that where
they're like oh i can get attention
from like everyone um i found
this quarter the 20 20 quarter
it has bats on it let me see does it
really have that it has [ __ ] bats on
it they're cute bats but they're wait
this is crazy
is that like a troll from the mint from
the [ __ ] i don't know how
they make decisions with coins and what
who green lights it's gotta be like that
that's so
weird it really does have a bat on it is
this a fake prank
i don't know i don't i don't it looks
very real but i oh this is a quarter
dollar oh that is a quarter
i was like do a quarter dollar i'm
keeping this
isn't that crazy why does it say that
it's 30
dollars on etsy oh it's a little baby
bat
wait it's like a rare quarter worth
money esther's three dollars
three dollars sister esther still wants
it
she got her grubby little fingers on oh
i touched it first
why is it uncirculated i see what does
it say
why is it a bat guys when the bats
brought us this maybe because it's a
mole
maybe it's like a fruit bat thing how
did i get a quarter who
i haven't used cash in a year and a half
oh you have laundry in your house you
rich
i i can't wait for the day i don't need
quarters
when i look at them like esther like
it's a quarter dollar what does that
mean
[Laughter]
i do think that's a collectible item i
start you
this is crazy my vagina also is i've
only seen this look
once before do you think that
um we should sell molds of our vaginas
you just said collectible item and
vagina listen i didn't know
where you were going that's like porn
that's porn
but also timmy it's like you're not
going to see my vag that's yeah
that's my that's like like you gotta
earn that's for me and donut
that's for me and several which is weird
because it looks like a donut but
they go donut to donut option no i like
yeah that's for me and about well who
knows how many guys let's be real
kalila the episode of tiger belly with
trisha paytas
is like unbelievable yeah and and
well andres um oversaw that whole thing
and i think
he will he probably he had six pages of
notes after that
sweating from both of his armpits i
could really see a connection between
trisha and bobby
i like towards the end i was really
seeing it how they are
similar and it was interesting how bobby
was saying he was like jealous of her
freedom to just say whatever
it's amazing what she can do and also
from that episode when bobby was talking
about
how he is like around like
basically like a gargoyle as you said
yeah and he's interested in like long
lean
i was like oh that is what truly why
when bobby looks at me he just sees
like nothing because i really look like
him
to him yeah he's always been with tall
women that's his thing i think he's
trying to offset his genetics
it is like funny to think of him hanging
off of you
he does have a considerable climb like
he does have to climb he actually has to
climb esther just to kiss you
he's to get on his shoulders we got to
put a trench coat on you guys you need
to be
sized it's very my height exactly
i don't know about you guys but i love
neutral when i turn 30
this is a real like insecurity of mine
for some reason when i got off the pill
my hair just started shedding i used to
cry about it
until i started taking neutrophil you're
not alone 30 million women are impacted
by weakened or thinning hair and if
you're among them know that
you are not alone because kalila is like
you too and so are all of us
and there's a solution that you can
trust to deliver results
thousands of women have taken back
control of their hair with neutrophil
with many users raving that the
supplement not only transformed their
hair but restored their confidence too
and i can
i can 100 attest to this it really is so
weird how much hair
will affect your confidence
it's very important and it's just not
something that um women can talk about
as freely as like men because there's so
many products in the market for men
i know we're like we lose hair too guys
neutrophil offers two targeted formulas
for women that are clinically shown to
improve hair growth and thickness with
less shedding through all stages of life
healthier hair
growth takes time you'll begin to
experience thicker stronger faster
growing hair in three
to six months imagine those pu zester
you can grow thicker
healthier hair and support our show by
going to nutrafull.com and entering the
promo code bloodbath to save 20
off your first month's subscription this
is their best offer
anywhere and it is only available to us
customers for a limited time
plus free shipping on every order so get
off at nutrafl.com it's spelled n-u-t-r
promo code bloodbath
is there anything that got cut from the
trisha paytas episode that you can share
with us here on bloodbath yes a lot
a lot and give us a piece
um it's not stuff that you guys don't
already know
she was basically that's why i sort of
felt like
i wasn't shocked by anything she said
it's stuff that like just generally like
being around like female comics like you
guys have either experienced yourselves
or
kind of have like similar opinions about
that male comics are disgusting
yeah yeah yeah she's she's correct
and because she she's really open about
it like what she she was an escort for
six years like in la
she just she she put herself in a
position
to really know the nasty part of
all of these did you ever hire oh my god
no but i relate to that putting yourself
in the position to like knowing the
nasty stuff because it's like
when i moved to la i hung out at the
comedy store till 3 a.m every night for
like a year and a half and it's like
yeah you just come across the wrong
people at the wrong time
and they're like they're gross i um
like annie until the pandemic stopped me
that is exactly what i've been doing for
about
seven years till three babies but
i think i sort of did the same i used to
pride myself in being like the bro
like the only girl that like dudes would
spill all their seed and i felt really
now i feel really gross about it because
i'm like i don't want to know that
who you're [ __ ] on the side yeah and
but then
my my therapist was like why do you feel
some type of way about it it's not yours
yeah it's not yours
and it's it is weird though like i
remember seeing this one guy who like
cheats on his [ __ ] girl all the time
and he's hit on you this guy has hit him
yeah he slid into his head
like sliding yes
we've had a couple conversations and it
just never went there
these comedians don't want me it's not
just the comedians esther
we're glad you're here today we wanted
to tell you but anyway so yeah so i i
see this guy with his like
family and at the mall and i felt
so guilty yeah
and but it was just like i felt like my
face was like
hot when i met and it wasn't like i've
done nothing
i've only rejected this person's
advances
yeah i've never like seen him hook up
with anyone else i just know from the
way he talks to me that he talks to
everyone else like this
and it was just so i mean i was just
bright red
i i mean i pulled it off i made some
joke about
you got a rich guy that's what i'm
saying it's like that second hand like
embarrassment or that secondhand
guilt that shouldn't even be guilt but
it's there because you just happen to be
like
the object of their like you know what i
mean
right but then it's like the trouble
you'd be in if you you were the person
like pulled them aside and were like hey
oh yeah that would just and it never you
always are
the one that gets [ __ ] when you do
that you never ever ever
help this that's oh the girl will like
call you a liar or whatever you know
it's just like such a wonderful it is
also not your business to do that
yeah but it is be in other female comics
you just talk about this it's like we're
put in an uncomfortable position when
people are coming out to the clubs with
their like
mistresses or whatever and like what are
we supposed to do like i don't know just
it puts everybody in
uncomfortable if bobby were to bring in
a
11 an 11. really your old girl
yes i would tell you and she is
so hot but also so nice and so funny
like funnier prettier across the board
made you guys laugh and he was like hey
just don't tell kalila but you guys
really liked her
what would you tell me yeah we would
never tell you
we wouldn't tell you we don't care about
you and we want to keep this podcast
we want this studio because we don't
want to have to move studios because
that's
different like we're actually because we
don't want that it is our business if
we're friends
yeah yeah and the truth is like it's
just
i don't know i just feel like i'm like i
didn't i live a
i live a life where i make my choices
and you know and you never know like
maybe they have an open relationship you
don't know what they're into or what
they're doing khalil and bobby
i mean i i yeah i'll tell you it's very
[ __ ] close guys it's very [ __ ]
close
we don't we don't do that okay it's so
close they don't even bang each other
i've been running solo for you these are
clothes let's just say that
bobby's he's getting bagged currently
but there's male comedians that i've
been friends with where i
like they've said to me oh that girl's
so you know hot or whatever like don't
tell
and then they say their girlfriend's
name yeah and i'm just like okay
yeah i don't know it's just i just it's
a tricky situation
i just i'm glad i'm not in those
situations myself
but yeah trisha that trisha tiger really
episode was incredible i really hope we
can have her on our show she said she
would
we were waiting for this to naturally
happen for us to all just naturally
get our periods in sync but since that's
not seeming to happen i
wanted to do a ceremony what do you mean
this is our period sinking ceremony
oh we were trying to period sync today
yes because here's the thing guys
what you don't know is that at what
pretty much every episode one of us is
on our period and it's
it's intense it is it's but you know i'm
about to be on mine and i don't get
[ __ ] i just get um emotional and
serious i think we are the only ones
that can really tell you what you get
and both of you okay tell me how i am
pre-menstrual
i get i cry easily like i'll cry
at something and i'm like oh that's my
period that's exciting i can't
i can't wait to find out when that isn't
so we're going to do a seance like we're
trying to sink
or we're going to sink our blood i have
a little period blood here for everyone
uh what
annie has harvested her own period blood
and oh we're doing a transplant she
it's like how does it work but we have
to get down
do you guys know the um bridge pose when
you for your ass
yeah i'll get down in it and we're gonna
wait hold on we're gonna do
this then like backwards like the
exorcist coming down
it's gonna be like it's gonna be like uh
ash wednesday but it's gonna be oh i
thought
it was trash tuesdays no i think we
should do the yoga wheel like the
exorcist and then you can
um um badge in the air vag in the air
i am out you're the only flex you're the
only one who can do this
esther you're out the blood's dripping
from your finger annie
if you think it's dripping from my
finger all right so i'll start
you gotta go you have to say um tampax
[Laughter]
what are the other ones called tampax
tampax
it's like candy man okay esther
you have to do it fine oh my god do you
have any um
harvested clots give me a this better
not make me break out
i hope it makes what of what you're
boring
oh it feels hell and let me prepare
myself my feelings
when you touch me all right hold on let
me put my head
10 packs 10 packs 10 packs
okay
what is this made out of i can i want to
taste your period blood
do you want to try some i'll taste your
period blood annie
can i get a clot okay i have a question
are clots miscarriages
[Laughter]
what do you mean you're just like losing
a baby every month
well like no not every month but you
know okay sorry to the guys or people
who are squeamish whatever we deal with
this
okay sometimes when you have your period
it's there's chunks in there
and i'm just wondering if when there is
a chunk
when there's a chunk does that mean that
there's a possibility that that that was
a miscarriage no it's an endometrial
line that you've just been pregnant like
several times
we call it in the philippines we call it
apollo no isn't it that line the uterine
lining
yeah it's a uterine lining it's a
uterine lining us sir
sometimes it's thicker yeah why is it
chunky sometimes i think everybody's
different
you never get to have more you tend to
have more cramps right yeah really bad
and does it um usually coincide with
the big chunky days i don't know
because i i didn't grow up i don't i
very rarely have cramps and i very
rarely have clots
so i don't know if there's a correlation
there but my sister not only is her body
skinny but so is her period it was her
uterine lining
only three days max no fudgies oh my god
i'm like seven days
gushing blood just clots everywhere i
had a boyfriend who literally like i
went in the bathroom goes
how did it get up there i don't know
that's like when i eat macaroni and
cheese and it's on my forehead
i'm like i don't know babe
i can't believe esther would need
crickets but she's totally down with my
vaginal fluids
and she offered to scoop our juices
okay going back to titanic talk because
you do think you're gonna
you would survive yeah how do you think
each of us would have survived the
titanic
i i'll go first if you guessed this
right
actually i want to guess everybody's i
think that i would do some sort of scam
like pretend i'm somebody's child or
a boy i'll be like oh my mom is in that
one you'll pretend you're a girl so you
can go first
i i think kalila's beauty like someone
would just be like
oh that beauty but i don't have like
regal beauty
i have like you know what i mean like
street beauty
no i don't have like old-fashioned like
evergreen beauty i don't want your low
self-esteem to go away
because it keeps you with us yeah you're
so delusional and crazy
i think i know how you're going to
survive annie how i think she
befriends the oh she's not [ __ ]
[Laughter]
she clings to my coattails i think
that's what you guys are going to do
you're going to pretend to be the mother
and that's your kid
i was literally going to just i was
going to just use you as a buoy was my
plan
no chester under up everywhere annie
goes she's
makes friends with everyone she meets
she's chatty cathy all the workers too
like that's what i'm saying like you
would have been in the boat the
the staff the kitchen staff you would
have known you would have
like threatened people with knives i'd
be requesting [ __ ] to the band i'd be
like let's play
like semicharm kind of life i'd be like
let me get some [ __ ] crab rangoon
someone on the staff or someone in the
lifeboat someone's gonna be like we want
her
like save her yeah but when the boat is
too heavy
you are the first to go we're gonna go
wow this is hour seven we're done
i'd be out off the boat very fast i was
thinking um
we used to go to phone parties did you
ever go to i know esther didn't because
she would have been enveloped by the
phone
well she would have walked away with
hives all over her she would have been
like completely
unseeable they they just released phones
you would have died at a film party i
think
when i heard of that in college i was
like what
like no how like i was so excited like
the little kid in me that likes baths
was like
how do you get the phone did you think
it was like it was like foam like
stuffed animals
no you set him up and pretended he wrote
the club my sister got a really bad rash
all over her body
yeah it's really pretty gross i mean
it's pretty gross but it's fun and it's
like
very like genital grabbing like you can
definitely like
do things no one can see but esther you
would be like at crotch level like you
would be getting face [ __ ]
accidentally like
doesn't the foam just disappear really
fast
no it's just there they just keep
pumping it out have you ever
i've never done a film party by the way
it's fun i refuse we should do one in
here
but i've been to ensenada when i was 18
or 17 sometimes
i would go drive to mexico and one time
i showed a picture of
um myself at pappas and beer with my
tits out
and like a really old man like licking
tequila off my tits and i showed it to
bobby and he cried
oh he was like you were just a young
young girl
and this old person like you were like i
am the best you're like i have the best
throwback thursday
you're not even gonna believe how funny
this is i had that where okay i have a
friend
i thought we were talking about foam my
my fir
my um first head shots were i was a
waitress at this place life cafe that i
mentioned
and um the lower east side or the sorry
east village and there was my friend
mario used to come in and
you know obviously i've been part of
that run but mario is a photographer so
i was like hey will you do my head shots
for free and he's like
uh i don't really do headshots but okay
so i was like i have this really good
idea i'll be like the girl that fell
asleep first i'll draw dicks i'll write
like [ __ ] and stuff on my face
but um it was an attempt so i did all i
did like draw the dicks and everything
and like had jizz like going to my face
and then when the pictures came out he
was like these are the least funny
because he's a getty photographer so he
photographs war
and like and bat like his friends have
been killed in battle
and it looked like i had been raped on
the street and he was like the first
person to like catch me before i went to
the police
it's like the saddest head shot you've
ever seen i will send it to you guys to
post
i have to see that okay this is really
weird because kali you said that your
cats
go crazy for your ear wax donut
my dog is walking around the premises
and she will keep sniffing at your
earbuds
oh should i try putting her near my ears
i'm like is do you have a magical ear
wax that animals like
are you gonna start i can put it in a
petri dish for you
q-tip i i don't q-tip because you're a
healthy person
no i have really [ __ ] up ears i have
swimmers here
and i have sometimes my hearing just
goes out
um so she must be sensing the fact that
i have some type of
cancer yeah my auditory nerves a fungus
wait i have a question krista stefano
when i did his podcast told me not to
get botox in my armpits because he can
give you cancer
i i wouldn't take any medical advice
from christos stefano that's why i'm
asking that's why i'm asking you i mean
on hpv i'll i'll take his advice because
i know he's
got it and nobody should be taking
medical advice from me either about
botox by the way but i exclusively do
yeah
i used to get botox on my hands and feet
for six years i did it with kylie
jenner she didn't like she went and saw
a palm reader and she didn't like what
they said so she got the wrinkles out
she wanted to live longer i think that's
why i have such pretty hands but
um um they were atrophied so bad like
the muscles were just
my fine motor skills were all gone like
i would walk around like i couldn't even
hold the pen anymore because the
hands were so dry that the pen would
stick to the track it never even
really got dried like i had to do this
every three months and each hand i would
get about 50 shots like fishing
tricks and it was so painful in my feet
even more just to not sweat
because it's not just the sweating it
was excessive sweating like i couldn't
walk around without a towel like i
couldn't go to school without smearing
all of them my armpits are dripping so
hard right now and they're hairy
this episode is sponsored by blue chew
guys this has been a hell of a year
personally i feel like i've aged 12
years over the last 12 months
i feel like that about you too but i
look so cute my tits are so perky
and if you're like us you might be
feeling your age more than you used to
especially
in the bedroom pop a hip every time it's
time to snap out of it spring is here
and it's time to get
sprung with blue chew blue tube is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost
if your girlfriend too has aged 12 years
and you no longer can get a boner from
her
boy blue chews tablets help men achieve
harder stronger
boners combat all forms of e.d
bluetooth is an online prescription
service so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations and no
waiting in line at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet package
the process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers
oh my gosh once you're boya
you'll receive your prescription within
days the best part it's all done online
blue chews licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient and strength for your
prescription and if you don't like
swallowing pills there's
no problems here because these tablets
that only kalila knows how to pronounce
it still dana phil and cidaleophil
are chewable imagine like each each chew
each bite were going like you can do it
boner you can do it
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important
safety information and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try blue
chew
free when you use our promo code bath
girls at checkout and you just pay five
dollars shipping guys we are passing out
boners do you understand we're giving
out free boners that's
blue bluechew.com promo code bathgirls
to receive your first month free
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast has your banana been on a break
too long let's get it back
have you guys heard of the term pick me
girl
no it's like so
relevant and useful i just learned about
it it's like cool slang
so a pick me girl is like a girl who's
like
i'm not like the other girls and
basically the idea is that they're like
performing so that a guy will pick her
so they're like i love sports like they
say and act
like so the guys will like them and what
ends up happening is there's a
girl with short hair with that's about
knuckle deep
trust me it's happened to me what do you
mean
you eventually just attract women why
because you're you're pretending like
sports you're doing all these like
things here i'm gonna pull up the real
definition
a pygmy girl is a girl who seeks male
validation by
indirectly or directly insinuating that
she is quote
not like other girls kind of like a simp
but for girls otherwise known as
internalized
misogyny not the easiest to explain but
when you see one you'll know
she's one for sure usually this does
this to be accepted by one of the boys
and considered one of the good ones
so it's basically a simp but but a girl
yeah but i just said
like you can do that is basically like
um
like male like feminists um esther's
definition makes sense to me i'm not
like other girls
simp is someone who does way too much
for a person they like
okay i need a symp i
he's a simp like for like tiny tasks and
only when he knows like i'm mad
really then it's like i have so much
love is it for sex or is it for
admiration um for apologies he's
definitely a bottom
sexually and i love that what does that
mean
his energy is of a bottom like he he
he wants mama to take i'm a top a top or
a bottom esther
i'm a middle i'm a child
[Music]
um yeah so in some situations like he is
i love that he's so like
kind of asleep sometimes
least amount of work the bottom but you
could be on the top if they really
worked it
but you can be a very active bottom
and when they're spinning you it's like
you're not really doing it oh my god
i have never and i've asked him he's so
afraid terrified of any ass play like
terrified
like i can't even yeah he's i don't know
what it is
but i can't no finger no nothing i've
been with most men that i've been with
definitely like ass play except for him
have you packed anyone have you ever put
like a strap on and i've never pegged
anyone but i've definitely fingered
asses i feel like i would like to peg
but i would never be attracted to the
guy because i want my man to be a man
you know
he's like if todd was like [ __ ] me in
the ass i'd be like i'd be so into that
man i love that it doesn't make them not
a man but i still get pegged
it's okay that you're not into that but
i don't think it makes someone not a man
to me it does to me sexually my vagina
doesn't feel like they're a man
i would be so terrible there is
something
if i think that if bobby would let me
peg him
because it is something that like i
think that would really i'd really enjoy
because i have natural a natural desire
to thrust forward
i would like to try i would like to try
it but i'm telling you it can't it would
ruin my
relationship you should do it to a woman
oh
do you have any that are available i've
i've never done it and i'm not
i don't have that drive to do that like
you do
honestly no i think it could unleash you
that is eating crickets should be like
i'm just like happy with what i've got
yeah me too
i have a friend who there is this
i try not to give too much information
away here but she would basically like
take an uber to this guy's house like
three times a month just to
number one warm up with eating his
[ __ ] and number two peg him
and that's what he was into like and he
was a a straight guy he was a successful
like ceo
but you can like come from because i
think it's a lot of like it's guys are
like powerful in their life and then
they want to not be like
they want to be like dominated in bed
but
do you cut do girls like doesn't it hit
their [ __ ] while they're doing it
i'm not sure how it works i don't know
the mechanics does adam and eve
we should ask a lot of i should just ask
one of my best friends she's
she's a lesbian so of course she's had
strap-ons before i i can't imagine
she couldn't every time i've asked a
lesbian like what they do they're always
like well
they're like you'll find out i'm like
tell me
and you have found out how you found out
they do scissors i actually used to
think that scissoring was like just
something that guys like thought was
funny
but i recently talked to a lesbian and
she's like no scissoring is real what
part of you talk to her
[Laughter]
my mouth i just can't i just like
from a ergonomical standpoint it just
doesn't seem like you get the most bang
for your buck
with scissors yeah it's like you're
working too hard
for not a lot like but once you get this
the the scissors in they're in well
you're into you're not like
scissoring each time so it's like then
you're just mush mush then it's just a
forest fire i would rather where's the
insertion
like i look all i'm saying is
there's so much more you can do like
there's so much more i can do with my
electric toothbrush
than i could get from like a scissor
session that's what i would think but my
lesbian friend was like no
it's it works we want to try
only fans guys only fans i know this is
we're all like in pl
we're all platonic friends but let's see
if we just blindfold each other
and we get into it like legs come to my
mid thigh that's not fair she's like the
little kid scissors that have like the
scallop let me tell you a fire would
erupt
the condition that i'm in right now oh
hair yes i just say oh i actually used
my manscape today and i i shaved myself
it's awesome for you
it is for me everything there's listen
there's two razors in my house
one is a regular razor and one is
manscape and they're shared
you gotta get more intimate i tried that
once and i used my friend's beard
trimmer
on my vagina and i thought it was funny
and he's like jokes on you that i use
that on my [ __ ]
but it's like scissoring there you go
scissored through one appliance i wanted
to say though when you're like
i don't think it makes you not a man to
i just want to say my
sexual what what makes me horny doesn't
mean
anything about what anyone does there's
no you cannot take what i feel and what
i think and make it
mean that you're being shamed i hate
that it's just
right now it's like i'm allowed to feel
the way i feel like someone was writing
something about my
like annie shouldn't be saying anything
about her arms being fat it's like
no i like think like as a woman and as
like someone who believes that people
can like
freely speak and feel what they want i
think my place on this earth is to just
like
say exactly how i feel and be
responsible for myself
yeah that's crazy to like encroach on
people's preferences i think
and like i'm not here for your
self-esteem like you got to build that
yourself like you got to go inward locus
of control and love yourself and we're
locus of control well like if you're
looking for like outward validation and
you can't feel good unless you get
outward
validation you have zero control over
those people
so now all you're doing is you're really
deflecting your own
moment to like learn grow and get good
inside yourself and you're now placing
the blame outward and it's like
you're going to live a miserable life
you're going to be constantly like
telling people they can't do that and
then
and like comments are just comments
whatever but and they're i we haven't
gotten a lot of those comments but i
just
that type of comment really i am not
responsible for how other women feel
about their bodies
i hope that me being honest and being
like [ __ ] raw and real
will let you be wrong real and [ __ ]
love yourself because i love myself and
i'm not going to [ __ ]
ever not make fun of my [ __ ] arms if
i want to put my arms
that's i i think that you're right about
that yeah i've had that experience
too where like my humor especially like
a few years ago was
very self-deprecating and i used to have
like all these comments even from people
i knew that were like
don't say this about yourself like don't
be like this but i was always like
well i'm just expressing myself and like
being trying to be funny
so it's actually like i don't really
appreciate you
telling me that i can't say how you know
i used to be like
my mom a funny joke trying to be funny
like my mom says this about me and how
i'm fat whatever and it's like
again that's how humor is how i express
like my insecurities she also eats binge
eats obviously
and so yeah i just relate to that like
it is a fine line and
yeah you where i think you are allowed
to express yourself
i think like that's what's good about
our part it's like we're not it's not
we're far from role models let's put it
that way and if you are
inspired by us or whatever be inspired
by the fact that we don't give a [ __ ]
whether you're inspired by us do you
know what i mean like live your life be
like
i live as authentically as you can i
think that's the message
even if it doesn't necessarily align
with
woke culture if it doesn't align with
things that were
you know just the general climate of
how things are today you know another
thing too is
i you know how we all have a friend
who's like i'm so fat today
and you look at them and in your head
you're like oh my god they're so not fat
like they're so beautiful and skinny so
i would i used to like when i was
younger i'd be like
i'd be like oh my god
what are you talking about you're so
perfect but now i try not to
say that because i i don't want to
invalidate your reality like if you're
feeling insecure like oh
like that sucks like i get it and also
it's like not
we shouldn't be able to make someone
feel like that's like some journey
someone's got to get to them
yeah and that'd be pretty wild if
someone was trying to
if i was imagine if i was doing that to
like seek
just or was i was fishing for validation
yeah you're not somebody else
you were spearfishing for validation
when i was spear fishing for validation
but
the truth of the matter is like i have
hated myself for a really long time
and um that's just the journey that i'm
on like i fluctuate there are days where
i feel like
really secure and wonderful and living
like authentically like
you know like honoring like who i am at
my core but
other days i am just you know
a mess and it's okay too and it would
not be helpful
if you said i hate myself and i was like
why do you hate yourself i don't hate
you you're yeah but instead to be like
okay i hear you today you hate yourself
i hear that
my best friends and i we went through
more than just the freshman 15. like we
all
got really really like we put on like 30
40 pounds yeah man quarantine hello
and literally but there would be times
where let's say like oh
we all decide to go on a night out and
let's say my friend jessica's just like
you guys like
i'm feeling really ugly i've tried on
nine different outfits i'm just not
feeling
it today i would look at her and i would
be like
you need to stay home you're right
you're not looking your best and
vice versa she would be like either
she would just be so blunt with me
because we're that close like she knows
what i'm insecure about
and if i'm really just not having like a
visually good day
she's like stay your [ __ ] [ __ ] like
don't go showing that [ __ ] around town
like i'm not liking that
[ __ ] i'm getting all the good dick come
on you ugly [ __ ] let's hop on in
no i feel like but i mean i will
actually i mean even though i'm
like i hear what you're saying about
like i hear you whatever but i will
still tell you guys you're pretty
because it is like
you know you you are and that's truly
what you feel like
yeah but i'm like i understand you don't
see this but i'm just gonna let you know
from the outside point of view which
shouldn't matter
like and it won't it won't affect me
then when you say kalyana shut up you're
you're you're really pretty yeah
and then at that moment there's like no
net effect but later on like
8 you know annie did stay hostage i'm
not gonna lie i won't
help yeah i i will only lie i like
calling esther ugly because it's so
funny
look at her it's ugly it's not is that
funny look at how good she is
but if she feels like i would never say
that to her i believe that esther
knows what she's got
at least can manipulate people into
thinking she's got it
okay hang on so i grew up um
did you guys ever learn to like make
haikus or ride haikus
with a five seven five i don't like any
parameters like that
are you just gonna freestyle that are
you just gonna rap yeah i just
i don't like i don't like you this many
syllables give us your bars then
there's no there's no rules then okay
what was my opponent
i had one for us to remember oh that's
right that's right she i had to
transcribe this for
for you hang on one second i have to
have a right see this esther you don't
that's
something else would be jealous of you
already esther me saying a thing and
someone writing it down for me
esther this is annie's love love poem
for you
here it goes there's no title i want to
punch you into space
i want to punch you into the stars i
want you to get a concussion
hit your head into mars it was
originally written for todd but
it just seemed fitting
thank you i would love to be in the
stars so thank you
did you guys hear my stars did you guys
know that
in the beginning of my relationship with
bobby that i
i told him that i want ew i forgot that
was there
i told him that i wanted to be a poet
and he laughed in my face oh it's so
embarrassing
three days he was like well what do you
want because i was having a meltdown
about
nursing i was like maybe i'll just do
nursing after all he's like it's not
what's in your heart what's in your
heart and i was like
i want to be opposed oh and then he
laughed at you
and he laughed for three days he was
like you cannot do that
and i was and i had just read him all my
poems and he was like they're great
sweetie but you can't be a poet
really that one is tough for me that's a
crisis right there but i'd rather
let's just say i'd rather peg you okay
what made you quit nursing
how they're gonna say what made you quiz
quit poetry oh
you guys are being supportive of my
dreams um it was it was never something
that i was really like wait what's your
favorite
poem poem that you wrote oh one about my
dad
but i can't read it because i i'll cry
well what's your second favorite one
i told you i wrote a poem about pigeons
was it slam poetry
no i don't do slam poetry i do very um
oh
there it is esther that's that is poetry
i finally got my kiss
from my little princess esther no haiku
from you
i it's on my computer at home here let
me read did carlos write it for you no i
wrote it on the plane recently
a real poem yeah a haiku oh a high
quality you guys i have to go on a plane
soon to see my parents i have to live in
15 minutes oh that's right
i'm so excited what are you gonna do um
i'm gonna hang out with my dad for a
little bit
and like nap a little and then we're
gonna take their car and go to todd's
house
his mom's gonna make us fu she's laotian
but she loves making fuss or she's
making me [ __ ] your parents are meeting
um i actually haven't planned them
meeting each other but we were going to
just kind of
take the car and go how far uh his
parents are in jersey so it's like
probably
half hour 40 minutes that's it yeah i
have
always like managed to date guys that
their parents live so close to my family
so you're gonna basically the whole trip
is gonna be going like back and forth
back and forth and then
on thursday we're going to boston to
surprise my nieces i've
surprised them um three times before one
time i was
i was wrapped under the christmas tree
one time i was in a box like i rang the
doorbell and i just popped out of a box
um one time i was in the trunk of the
car when they came back from school
and then this time my sister-in-law has
industrial-sized trash bags so i'm just
going to be in a trash bag next to them
and like
i'm going to jump out it's like i want
to scare the [ __ ] out of it why
that one's a good one they love it
because they're always like when's
auntie popping out my niece was like
why is auntie in a box she was three she
was like why is she not she was so
confused like her little brain couldn't
but they love it and they know i'm like
one day i'm gonna pop out of somewhere
like
when i found my folder of poems
read us a read us one you have to hold
on are we doing a love poem
or are we doing impressive a sad poem or
embarrass yourself actually actually i
would rather you be embarrassed
love poem is embarrassing probably yeah
the most embarrassing i think i can't
read you the one about my papa because
no
i'll cry yeah okay here you go
it's called the fourth i really need you
guys to get in
is this because you wanted another guy
to join your threesome no
it's like a fourth co-host to bloodbath
it's trisha please come on to our
podcast this is the seance please
stay on the fourth please join it's
called the fourth okay
i often wonder annie hates rhyming stuff
so i already know the judgment so i'm
just not gonna look at her
i often wander straight under into
places left unseen
and in those spaces where i plunder old
versions of me convene
it's really hard for me to pay attention
[Laughter]
it's just so hard i kept losing money
without i was just hoping we were gonna
stare for a really long time until she
really
really like put like a bullet hole in to
match that little blood
it's just hard it was at first i though
i was like oh
it's pretty i like it but then i just
saw yes
i hear yeah wait wait wait but i have a
question so this is about the different
versions of yourself like and the
decaying mind is a
really woman when you're i'm not you
guys when you're an old person no wait
when you're an old person
the decaying the fourth is trisha paytas
okay no but is it the decaying mind is
when you're an old lady
um no the fourth is who i am today the
first
the second and the third are old
versions of me that no longer serve me
okay so i don't like it i don't like it
as much as i thought it would be i did
brilliant when i thought you were doing
like like the decaying mind was like you
as an elderly woman in your mind and i
was like
this is brilliant and she's like thank
you you're thanking them even though you
haven't even met them yet i was like
this is brilliant and now i'm like i
don't know can we just bleep out that
entire poem and just keep annie's
comments about it and just keep it a
mystery
oh no [ __ ] no way i think we should
okay wait i had to i'm not gonna
disclose too much information
but i had to sing on a video for
something
and i would rather my nudes be leaked
and when i say nudes i mean
really bad angle nudes like really like
not certified not agreed with like
will we will the public ever hear this
singing never
why why did you sing on a mystery video
it's for a thing i can't describe how
would you rate yourself as a singer
overall oh it's really bad and it's it's
truly the most embarrassing it's like a
boiling like my blood boiling like i can
feel heat in my face
yeah my toes it's just the worst that's
okay we found something that
i'm not afraid of doing that it's free
it's like your cockroaches
or your your crickets there's more than
crickets it's a lot of things
can can um our banana break be like a
singing break then
[Music]
i want a banana i want to be i want a
banana too disaster like bananas
i feel like esther's gonna start liking
all these things
you don't like bananas because of the
taste or the texture
uh it's almost there i just don't like
go
i don't reach for them because other
people like them i like them in a
smoothie though they make a smoothie
amazing would you say you're like other
girls like
bananas but you don't yeah like other
girls i'm a picnic are you pick me girl
not at all i hate men she's a pick me
last night
yeah i went don't pick me i like all
those comments about my
tits last week like i'm covered the [ __ ]
up now i have [ __ ]
unleashed mine i'm like excuse me no i
will i will wear shirts like that
when i find cute ones but i'm
i don't know i'm not i don't
i don't identify as a pikmi girl do you
don't you think that
trying to not be a pikmi girl is one way
of being a pikmi girl yes
[Laughter]
that's totally true yeah because you're
trying to just be go against the grain
yeah and trying to be like the cool
wallflower in the corner who doesn't
dress up and goes in all sweats because
i'm not going to wear you know but i
think that in itself is being a pikmi
girl because i don't think it is
young [ __ ] though too it's like you
eventually you just
chill the [ __ ] out you learn who you are
hopefully right you forget who you are
kalyla no because the difference between
when i go out
and i'm in my normal t-shirt and sweats
versus if i'm
in a sh in a skirt or shorts or
even just a dress the male attention
is night and day i don't it's really
weird how the male brain works i'm like
literally just me wearing a dress you
view me as like a
possible mate that's why i do feel bad
for like
this super beautiful perfect body model
women because the men hey i'm fine
the men that are the men that are
attracted to them i feel like are not
maybe not so not so good whereas the
gargoyles that kleila and i
attract number one
i like to dress slightly molested that's
my love what does that mean
like just like things are a little
smaller than you would think for someone
my age
i really do love the fact that you dress
exactly the way i did in high school
right to the t because i was a baby [ __ ]
well thank you for listening and please
like this video comment
below we have to put subscribe in the
beginning and subscribe
and i'm coming to phoenix april 29th
so if you guys want to go out of town
that's a great weekend to get out of
there
nothing going on standuplive.com i
have some special things planned and a
special guest i'm very excited so
standuplive.com for tickets to see me in
phoenix
april 29th what else i will be
[ __ ] nowhere i have no dates i will
be here
i have a bunch of dates coming up but
they're i don't have them confirmed yet
but they're
soon and they're gonna be great bye guys
we'll see you next week bye guys
subscribe
like smash all the buttons
[Music]
you